lo que estamos viendo en este vídeo es
una forma mecánica de pensar en el
corazón casi como si fuera un par de
bombas unidas con tuberías de cierta
manera no es una forma tan mala de
pensar en el corazón vamos a explicar
este diagrama aunque ahora me doy cuenta
que parece un poco aterrador
sin embargo cuando empecemos a etiquetar
las partes veremos que no es tan malo
como parece así que empecemos en la
parte de arriba del corazón tenemos a la
aurícula derecha a de la sangre baja al
ventrículo derecho
vd y del otro lado etiquetamos las otras
dos cámaras la aurícula izquierda
y el ventrículo izquierdo v
y vamos a seguir el camino de la sangre
después de dejar el ventrículo derecho
vamos a empezar nuestro viaje aquí en el
ventrículo derecho y entonces con que
nos cruzamos primero bueno la sangre
deja el ventrículo derecho pasa a través
de una válvula y después tenemos un área
por aquí dibuje un tubo sin divisiones
que se llama tronco pulmonar la sangre
se dirige hacia los pulmones pasa
primero por este tronco pulmonar y
después de él están las arterias
pulmonares y recordemos se llaman
arterias porque la sangre sale del
corazón hay dos arterias pulmonares la
izquierda y la derecha y es por eso que
vemos dos tubos por aquí uno aquí y otro
acá y estos son básicamente tubos la
sangre pasa por el tronco pulmonar se
divide en uno de estos dos tubos y se
dirige a los pulmones en la parte de
arriba están los pulmones el izquierdo y
el derecho y aunque ya sabemos que los
pulmones
de esta forma que esto no es
anatómicamente correcto pero como
mencionamos en un inicio esta no es una
mala forma de pensarlo la sangre pasa
por los pulmones y sale del otro lado y
después pasa por las venas pulmonares
izquierda y derecha es importante que
aclaremos que no hay solo dos venas
pulmonares una para cada pulmón de hecho
hay muchas más de ellas entonces al
dibujar esto lo que debemos pensar es en
los dos lados y las venas partiendo de
ellos son algunas venas pulmonares las
venas pulmonares vierten la sangre en la
aurícula izquierda ahora estamos del
otro lado del corazón y por el momento
vamos a pausar el viaje aquí empezamos
en el ventrículo derecho pasamos por los
pulmones y estamos de regreso en la
aurícula izquierda esta es la primera
parte de nuestro viaje que llamaremos la
circulación pulmonar
qué es este primer circuito donde
empezamos en el corazón y acá vamos de
nuevo en el corazón el corazón tiene dos
circuitos pero los mostraremos uno por
uno por ahora ya hemos completado uno de
ellos vamos a tomar pintura azul para
indicar la sangre de shock sigue nada o
la sangre sin oxígeno vamos a pintar
cómo se ve y podemos observar como la
sangre de 'shock' sijena da va del
ventrículo derecho al tronco pulmonar
pasa por las arterias pulmonares y llega
a los pulmones derecho e izquierdo una
vez allí se mezcla en los capilares
empieza a obtener oxígeno y sale del
otro lado por las venas pulmonares esas
venas pulmonares llevan la sangre
oxigenada a la aurícula izquierda es
decir lo que acabamos de colorear es la
circulación pulmonar esta es la primera
parte de nuestro circuito
ahora vamos a seguir y hablaremos de la
segunda parte del sistema circulatorio
que es la circulación sistémica
ahora el nuevo viaje empieza en el
ventrículo izquierdo e iremos alrededor
del cuerpo el cuerpo es el que recibe
toda la sangre cuando decimos cuerpo nos
referimos a varias cosas como los
órganos por ejemplo el cerebro o el
hígado o también cosas como los huesos o
los dedos de los pies cualquier parte de
tu cuerpo que puedas imaginar todos
estos órganos y tejidos distintos
recibirán sangre del ventrículo
izquierdo
inicialmente la sangre pasará a través
de un vaso gigante ese vaso lo etiquetar
hemos aquí como sabes es la aorta por
supuesto se ramifica y se divide no
vamos a dibujar aquí todas las
ramificaciones que salen de la aorta
pero hay muchas de ellas la sangre va a
todos esos órganos y tejidos y después
regresa por el otro lado y al final
llega por acá arriba a la aurícula
derecha a través de dos grandes vasos
una es la vena cava superior y la otra
es la inferior que significa la vena
cava de arriba y de abajo las dos son
venas capas vena cava superior y vena
cava inferior estas son las dos penas
más grandes y traen la sangre de todas
las partes del cuerpo de regreso al
corazón
ahora podemos ver la segunda circulación
completa ya que terminamos en la
aurícula derecha y esta es la
circulación sistémica
ahora puedes ver que el corazón
introduce dos circuitos diferentes en el
primero en la circulación pulmonar el
ventrículo derecho funge como bomba en
el segundo el ventrículo izquierdo funge
como bomba ahora podemos colorear el
resto del circuito la sangre oxigenada
llega a los órganos diversos y los
órganos usan el oxígeno por lo tanto la
sangre ahora des oxigenada en azul
regresa a la aurícula derecha esta es la
forma en la que vemos este circuito una
vez más esto no nos muestra una
apreciación de la anatomía exacta es
decir donde se ramifica cada cosa y de
dónde provienen los diferentes nombres
pero podemos tener un panorama general
de que tenemos dos circulaciones
diferentes y podemos ver por dónde va la
sangre en cada uno de los dos circuitos
ahora cuando observamos este diagrama
podemos decir ok podemos ver de dónde
obtienen sangre
todos los tejidos distintos básicamente
toda la sangre oxigenada viene del
ventrículo izquierdo pero algunos
tejidos nos hacen generar una pregunta
así que vamos a mencionar un par de
tejidos que nos generan esta pregunta
uno de ellos no es realmente un tejido
pero en definitiva es un tipo de célula
son los glóbulos rojos y la típica
pregunta es si los glóbulos rojos llevan
la sangre a las otras partes del cuerpo
entonces cómo se oxigenan ellas usan un
poco de oxígeno que llevan o cómo es
exactamente para responder tenemos que
recordar que los glóbulos rojos se ven
como una sección transversal como esta y
no tiene ninguna mitocondria
tienen mitocondria y recordemos la
mitocondria es un orgánulo pequeño
dentro de las células que usa oxígeno
por lo tanto al no tener mitocondria en
realidad no usa oxígeno este tipo de
células no tienen mitocondrias ni
tampoco tienen núcleo literalmente son
células diseñadas maravillosamente con
el propósito de llevar oxígeno al cuerpo
ya que de manera puntual son bolsas de
hemoglobina por lo tanto recuerda los
glóbulos rojos no necesitan oxígeno
simplemente lo transportan
otro tejido que nos hace cuestionarnos
es el corazón el corazón bombea toda la
sangre pero será cierto que obtiene
oxígeno de los vasos que están en la
circulación pulmonar o en la circulación
sistémica ok la respuesta corta es que
lo obtienen de la circulación sistémica
vamos a observar los vasos sanguíneos de
donde lo obtienen estos vasos se llaman
vasos coronarios tenemos una vena
coronaria y una arteria coronaria estos
vasos coronarios salen de la aorta justo
aquí de hecho de las primeras
ramificaciones de la aorta las primeras
ramificaciones sirven al corazón así que
él es el primero en obtener sangre de la
circulación sistémica y las venas
vierten esa sangre directamente a la
aurícula derecha es decir hay un cierto
lugar donde esta sangre se drena así que
la sangre del lado de la arteria la
obtiene de lado
por el lado de la pena la sangre no se
vierten en la vena cava superior ni en
la inferior un dato curioso es que la
vierte directamente en la aurícula
derecha
finalmente el último tejido engañoso los
pulmones de donde obtienen oxígeno a los
pulmones dije engañoso y por eso lo dejé
al último recuerda por ahora no nos
preocuparemos por los términos
anatómicos perfectos es decir de dónde
vienen exactamente pero existen vasos
sanguíneos que vienen de la circulación
sistémica tenemos un vaso que va al
pulmón derecho y tenemos otro paso que
va al pulmón izquierdo de esta forma es
decir un par de arterias que se
ramifican y que también son parte de la
circulación sistémica
a estas se les llama arterias
bronquiales y estas arterias bronquiales
llevan una magnífica sangre oxigenada al
pulmón y mencionamos vasos bronquiales
porque también hay penas que recogen la
sangre dibujemos esas venas para que
veamos dónde terminan las venas salen
del pulmón y terminan aquí no puedo
encimar azul en azul pero debemos
confiar en que terminan aquí y por
supuesto tenemos otra vena del otro
pulmón que sigue un camino paralelo y
que desemboca en estas otras venas estas
venas no se vierten de manera directa en
la vena cava superior o inferior pero
estamos mostrando que llegan a la parte
venosa de la circulación sistémica así
que esto es todo bastante sencillo sin
embargo los pulmones son interesantes ya
que allí se mezcla todo allí tienes
arterias pulmonares que llevan sangre
tienes arterias bronquiales que llevan
sangre y la sangre se mezcla en los
capilares
sangre de ambas partes llega sangre de
la circulación pulmonar y de la
circulación sistémica de nuevo esta
sangre se mezcla y por otra parte las
venas llevan sangre de nuevo al corazón
la mayoría de la sangre sigue el camino
a las venas pulmonares y aunque tienes
arterias bronquiales llevando sangre por
acá la mayoría de la sangre determinada
dirigiéndose a la circulación pulmonar
este es un hecho interesante que no toda
la sangre vaya directamente la
circulación sistémica esta es una parte
engañosa que debes de tener en cuenta
los pulmones
técnicamente obtienen sangre de ambas
partes de la circulación sistémica pero
también mezclan la sangre con la
circulación pulmonar hablaremos un poco
más de esto en otros vídeos
no quiero que sientas que esto es
bastante confuso sólo quiero que sepamos
que se lleva a cabo una mezcla en los
pulmones entre la circulación sistémica
y la pulmonar y es por ello que es un
órgano genial
sentido